uh michael jordan for instance right and  then you guys  uh kind of went back and forth was he he  was  what was he the he was the owner of the  team that you played for how how did  that work out with my with you and mike  yeah um at that time i'd um i was with  uh  golden state and i wanted to get traded  and they traded me to charlotte mike  traded for me  and uh he was the owner at the time and  uh you know mike is a competitive guy  he's somebody we all look up to and um  we're both guys both competitive guys  and he challenged me one day in practice  because the team wasn't playing well  and um he decided to get in the mix get  into practice and try to start some  things up to try to get us going and  work  to where me and him had words going back  and forth but it was  it was good for us and it was good for  the team morale because we needed that  at the time